alright one of the original cast members
of MADtv also enjoyed his work in How I
Met Your Mother the Goldbergs and so
much more movies like Bad Santa and the
hangover old school his new stand-up
special available now on the comedy
dynamics Network complicated Apes and is
highly popular fighter in the kid
podcast alongside Brendan Schaub all
about the UFC and more good to see you
Bryan Callen how are you good to be here
sir good to have you here spacious
wonderful unique office man office you
can explore the studio space here I know
I am I'm a lucky man good to have you
here man where do we start with you here
let's let's start with the UFC well what
the hell happen with Conor McGregor best
you can tell what is gonna I think that
a guy like that he did it right he took
the belt in two different weight classes
but you get when you get that rich
mm-hmm it's very hard I think to then
decide that you're gonna train on the
level that you did train and you gotta
remember these guys are not just
training that way they're sucking weight
they're taking they're dealing with
injuries all the time and then you get
in with a monster like khabib you have
to be so hungry there's so many people
coming after you it's very difficult to
motivate when you have $100,000,000
maybe after he's been fighting what
since he was 17 and you you made it you
did it you're at the top of the mountain
and when you like that view it's very
hard to come back down and just grind
like that
to his credit to that guy's credit he
fights anybody I couldn't believe he was
gonna fight khabib I couldn't believe it
I was like dude come up with any excuse
please
that guy is a nightmare if he touches
you that's it they hate that his level
of wrestling is so crazy
with the minute he closes the gap and
grabs you you're not going anywhere you
I have a track record of that those
daghestan ease they grow up wrestling at
the age of three and either by Jean that
whole area and not wrestling humans
either no sir no they'll wrestle bears
okay and they fight they fight I mean
it's just it's in it's a part of their
the geography of where they're from they
were dealing with the Turks with the
Russians with everybody else they had to
fight their whole life and yeah yeah I
was like you can't please don't fight
you're not a wrestler on that level you
can't solve that problem there's no way
to solve that problem I've just wonder
where to go from here now you know
obviously what is it the strong-armed
felony is how it was called
my Amory and strong-arm robbery robbery
it's a felony and he did with the cell
phone that apparently was held by a
khabib fan everyone's wondering what the
hell's going on with it's just that's
his height so but what what is next for
him I mean like shouldn't you just go to
a Guy Ritchie movie and just yes right
now I think he should get into movies
serious I really do your whiskey get
into movies right and he's done it he
did it he's proved everything to me so
he doesn't have to you know the again I
think that he has accomplished what
every fighter dreams of what's difficult
for these guys is when you've been
identified as a fighter when you love
that competition when you're an extreme
winner like he is it's very difficult to
then transition and now go be a movie
star go do acting which means wear
makeup and make believe and wait around
a lot that's that's not what it's
cracked up that's people saw how movies
were made
nobody would be interested in hanging
out or learning about actors right I'm
telling you right now you see you shoot
a page a day enjoy that right I don't
care what I've done all this movie I've
done big movies I was just on the Joker
I mean you know whatever it might be
you're sitting around you're you're
sitting around for your shot to come up
and if you're not in the shot you will
be in the background sir all day long
faked faking whatever it is you're doing
playing cards and action that's your day
for 12 hours please enjoy right
different women with your downtime we
could figure out inventive ways to get
your kids into school right you can do
thank you that I can't this is great
you've got a ten and a seven right got a
ten and a seven-year-old look I
understand I understand the desperate
need to protect right your kids get your
kids ahead in life but you can't cheat
you can't Photoshop your your daughter's
head on to you know I mean come on man
how these that the extent of these lies
when you're in a web that big you don't
think you're gonna get caught you don't
think that somebody's gonna figure it
out this is what cracks me up about
about people who try to pull off scams
and crimes you are a civilian you make
believe for a living you're an actor or
whatever you might be and then you
decide let's just tell like Jesse smile
at whoever it is you decide to step into
the arena of crime now what you don't
realize is that when you
side to pull off a scam like that you're
taking on the law enforcement agency of
Chicago of Massachusetts of loss and
this is the case it's the the FBI so
it's it's literally the equivalent of me
going you know what I think I'm in a box
at a high level I'm gonna get in there
with the Anthony Joshua or or I don't
know just take a big me and me enticed
inferior I'm gonna go and I get knocked
out and I'm surprised that's literally
what it is you kid you're not better at
crime than the people that study that
stuff so you know they just kind of go
oh look at this look at this amateur
let me just connect the dots and cuff
that person over Bryan Callen you're in
the rich assets you know my wife and I
have been you know talking about it for
last 24 hours and you go back and forth
but obviously between you do anything
anybody would do anything for the kids
if you have means or not you'll do
anything at your kids but I mean I'm
just cheat I know exactly and because
you do have to basically look your child
in the face say I know you'd want to go
to that school but guess what this is
life this is the way things go
you should have you we were telling you
to do better because of course it's the
kids fault it's not your parents core
exactly but you know I asked Chris Brock
when this before like what if you're the
kid and and like would how would you
feel if I Co by the way that that SAT
you took yeah totally rigged you didn't
even know it I mean I don't know example
mom and dad here look the bottom line is
that B we forget this there was a
constitutional lawyer who had who broke
down and the way our society works and
it's very simple to two rules three
rules really let's don't take what
doesn't belong to you keep your promises
in other words don't lie sure and if you
if you violate those to figure out a way
to make amends make it right justice is
by the Greeks to find this everything in
its place put it back in its place
everybody makes mistakes everybody has
moments man I mean oh that's part of
what my special is about we all we all
screw up okay today what's complicated
I'm not a noun I'm not I'm not a you
know I did did I'm a verb I change I my
take on the whole spectrum sinner and
saying everything in between yes I get
it man we all screw up but face the
music man make it right and I think
people forget that those simple things
and you know if you know those
things you learn right away as a kid
don't take what doesn't belong to me and
keep your promises Brian calendars
comedy dynamics but write it down so
let's return to - to the Octagon what is
the future for Cormier he's like it's
Lesnar and nothing the rest of the
heavyweight division is saying that's
not cool let's go
have you ever seen Daniel like in person
I have he's been here and he's a delight
he's he's one of my favorite he's to me
the most impressive fighter to ever step
in the Octagon why I don't know take a
look at him when he's in a polo shirt he
comes to my show sometimes when I'm in
San Jose I've actually I've actually
sparred with him which is this so
insulting but I got to get in there and
walk around with him yeah he was he was
doing this then he picked me up and put
his his shoulder into my chest and I
started producing estrogen and I
immediately I actually embraced him and
I and I think I cooked for him that
night no gosh I cleaned his floors Wow
by the way I do you do what Daniel tells
you yes but he's shorter than I am and
he looks he in a t-shirt he looks like I
don't know I thought my UPS guy isn't
that far off my UPS guys are thick dude
yeah but you know you wouldn't look at
my UPS guy ago that's the baddest guy on
the planet and Daniel Cormier has lost
only twice to two guys right I mean to
one guy John John's right that's the
only guy that has his number other than
that he is he's incredible
well he would also say that he did not
lose to Jon Jones either well again it
wasn't a fair fight you would say well
then and you know maybe there's a case
to be made there but there's no one more
impressive no one than Daniel Cormier I
just so what we're gonna do is he good
is he gonna wait for Lesnar or just not
fight at all I'd like to see him put a
beating on Lesnar I'd like to see that
and I want to see Daniel get paid I want
to see these guys get paid I want to see
Daniel sure make ten million dollars and
never have to worry he's just a he's
just a great human being yeah he's
turning 40 this week and he's dealing
with a back injury because he sneezed
which does not sound like an octagon
righty individual it does sound like he
he is he is a UPS driver yeah with all
you know by the way my UPS driver is
rock-solid he's not he came
he's got a abs he's got a beautiful body
he's in but see somewhere in between
Cormier and DK Metcalf who you were
remarking about from the combo I mean
Matt gasps I want if I look like that I
would never wear clothes where I walk
around on a loincloth are you kidding me
he's ridiculous I just be running I'd
run through I don't know I'm on the
beach I just be all I'd always be an
action or just posey on my honor but
compadre Daniel Jeremiah's sitting next
to me said he's a human bat suit is what
he call he's a human bat suit what I
think of that it's what he said he's
pointman bats I've just never when you
see a man like that like I look at him
and I'm like oh my god I thought I was
straight you know yeah so john jones
best-ever would you say he's best ever
that's what's being discussed now that
he's uh he just came off the W I mean
you got to give it up to him there's no
I mean I've he's just so creative how do
you solve that problem I have no idea I
mean again by the way both his brothers
are standouts in an organization called
the NFL national yeah yes so yeah I mean
just just when you play one down in the
NFL you're a better athlete and
everybody within ten square miles I
don't you know that's that's a fact and
his brother so that that gene pool but
he's but he's more than that he's just
he's a true fighter he's so creative his
ability to just stay kind of relaxed and
kind of let's see what I do maybe I'll
hit you with my elbow maybe I'll hit you
with a jab now I'm gonna front kick here
now I'm gonna do a weird thing with my
elbow you know he does these weird
things me he's you can't you can't game
plan for John Jones is there any way we
can get Cormier in the Octagon with him
one more time you think the only way I
would like to see Cormier fight I don't
want to see her may fight John Jones
again because I I love Daniel Cormier
and he has nothing to prove but if
Daniel Cormier was healthy and he fought
at heavyweight mm-hmm what would Daniel
Cormier do at 240 because that's what he
walks around that I think sorry Daniel
I know he's sensitive about that but I
mean you know that that would be the
only thing I'd be he's undefeated as a
heavyweight but again this John John's
John Jones makes mincemeat out of
everybody where it's not even a fight
has he finished everybody I believe
except for ovince st. Preux yeah which
was you know he was back and he's like
let me just and I'll play around a
little bit so I don't know man I I just
don't see anybody beat me I mean
Velasquez when he was younger and
healthy that would have been a great
fight the fighter in the kid podcasts
house Brendan's a comedy career doing he
just shot his special he's blowing up
and yeah did well again this is a pro
this is pro athlete discipline Brendan
Shawn yeah in show business yeah and
he's just a grinder he is a grinder he's
in grinder dude he's just one of those
guys he's so Metro he's so Metro he
walks when he spends a fortune on shoes
and hair product and skin product and
the whole thing and I just but he's make
no mistake he'll beat up everybody in
the room yes you know he's still an
absolute gorilla
and but it just cracks me up because
he's he's just a grinder and tough we
were we did this stunt where we had to
be on a horse and they were thinking
about maybe we'll fall off the horse but
it's a horse yes and he goes well why
don't we just both get on it and we'll
just the horse can gallop and will fall
off and I go yeah we'll just go I go no
no that's a horse and if it's going we
fall if there's nowhere to fall is the
ground did we get thistles and also
break my head my bones don't go well
with ground from horse and he goes he
goes don't be such a pansy
what a big you're such a baby that's how
he is yeah such a tough horse sounds
terrible oh my god yeah you think he was
mad at me because I didn't have I was
being a baby about falling off a
galloping horse not a stuntman comedian
alright I look like an athlete sure nice
my shoulders go on for days but still
before I let you go Bryan Callen you and
I have both been in a the same show not
at the same time but on this show
frequently I will open up on live
broadcast my residual checks from CSI
Miami I've appeared on two episodes of
CSI Miami one called deep freeze
and one called caged hmm did I I and I
was male reporter and one is that what
it was Chris yeah host and male I was
hosting one male reporter in another you
hold on a minute you played Kent
Ackerman don't remember it don't in a
2010 episode called getting axed IMDB
but I don't remember these things okay
you know so much everyone
so my resume goes on for days so I've
gotta ask you
yeah you know how big is your residual
check from CSI Miami you know no cuz you
get so many many it's so hard I have my
people tell you to go stuff it in that
horse you fell off of residual check is
from CSI you know you get a bug I've
been doing this for 25 years so I do get
a lot of residual check only get only
get a few by the way I got two more just
yesterday I'm gonna bring him in
tomorrow so it's on that are you getting
cuz I got I got two residual checks from
my appearance on the now-defunct
at midnight on Comedy Central on that
show the the residual checks were a
grand total of two cents and three cents
so I can you can buy that stamp I called
my son over my ten-year-old son over and
I'm like you know you want to go to
college right this is just to bring it
full circle the conversations going on
in Los you want to go for Mike I got
your college account right here right
yeah and um the two checks and he just
looks at me because this is two cents
dad do I do i cash that check now just
hold on to it do I catch the train sent
Chuck no cuz you can say dad was an
actor once a professional actor on
@midnight I was myself I wasn't I was
then you were in CSI so you were telling
a professional actor my my my on average
residual check is anywhere between three
cents and the whopping fine number
recently of like 11 bucks well let me
tell you this I did a little movie
called The Hangover ever heard of it
and hangover 2 whatever and bunch of
other stuff doesn't matter the point is
this I the first hangover we didn't know
was gonna be a big movie I think I got
paid a grand maybe 2 grand for the day
but then when the movie becomes uh-huh
you you know that's your college fund
there you go yeah
so bottom line guys I don't look at
price tags ok for the USC water polo
fund depending on what it is crazy Bryan
Callen calm with why / live to get
tickets to see Bryan Callen live the
fire in the kid podcast for all podcasts
can be acquired complicated ape stand-up
specials available right now on over 20
different platforms including DirecTV
and AT&T good to see you sir thank you
for having me say no thanks come back
anytime a lot of fun is it because it is
we had them reupholstered recently did
you really for me laughter I mean I mean
for you and others no I look good I look
good with a leather backdrop they go and
with leather on my legs and and chest
that's because you're not DK Cal DK
Metcalf that's exactly Bryan Callen on
Twitter as well as Instagram the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience